[Music]
the fact is
in millions of negroes as a result
of centuries of denial and neglect
have been left bootless
it is a cruel jest
to say to a bootless man that he ought
to lift himself by his own bootstraps
at the dawn of emancipation the total
black wealth in america was about
0.5 percent
today that number is between one to two
percent
so there's been practically no movement
i mean the most pernicious form of the
racial wealth gap is when we
take people human beings as capital for
others
as being an asset by which others can be
enriched
can accumulate can pass down resources
from one generation to the other
[Music]
they find themselves impoverished
aliens in this affluent
society and that is a great deal
that the society can and must do
if the negro is to gain the economic
security that he needs
the origins of the racial wealth gap
begins when
black people entered the shores of the
united states
as chattel capital
there were two forms in which black
people served as capital
the un compensated labor that they
provided
but their sheer bodies themselves could
be traded
could be traded and stood as a source of
wealth
and wealth building for white people
the enslavement of black people in
america is what made
the u.s economy grow into the powerhouse
that it is today
even though most of this farming
activity was going on in the southern
part of the united states
businesses all over the country were
involved in this
insurance companies insured the slaves
themselves
there were even slave-backed securities
that could be traded by financial
institutions
in essence slavery encompassed nearly
every part of the u.s economy at this
point
at the start of the civil war each slave
was worth an average of a thousand
dollars that came to four
billion dollars at that point because
there were around four million slaves in
the us
in today's money that comes to 42
trillion dollars
and 42 trillion dollars is about double
the size of the current
u.s economy
with the 13th amendment that freed
slaves
the point is that that's not enough when
you've had
centuries of literally bondage imposed
upon a people
if you want true justice or true freedom
there needed to be
not only that that freedom from bondage
but actual accompanying
of resources so that people could
pursue their livelihood expecting a
people to
to thrive and flourish without
compensation for all that unjust harm
really just set up a system for
oppression and a system that was unjust
toward the end of the civil war general
william tecumseh sherman
made a promise to slaves that as soon as
the war was over
they would be granted 40 acres of land
and a mule
this idea of giving land had a dual
purpose
people that supported it sought as a way
to both free
the formerly enslaved from their old
masters
and as a way to dilute the power of
these southern
land owners but a few months later
president abraham lincoln was shot and
killed
his vice president johnson swiftly got
rid of this promise
when andrew johnson vetoed the
friedman's bill he said look this is a
white man's government
so that that was the impetus but also
use this idea that like the government
doesn't give away
land this is capitalism and the idea
that this is a free market and laissez
faire was very much
used to undercut claims of the 40 acres
while at the same time the government is
giving away free land
out west through the homestead act the
homestead acts were a series of bills
meant to encourage settlement of the
american west
in all 270 million acres
were given out as part of the bills
that land which accounts for about 10
percent of the entire country
was mostly stolen from native americans
and most of the 1.5
million americans that benefited from
the homestead acts were white
they were literally giveaways that
provided white people
ultimately a key ingredient to build
wealth and that's capital itself
and by design black people were not
included the homestead act
is a dramatic indicator of u.s
government
facilitating the accumulation for white
people
and not facilitating it for black people
but it's one of many
the homestead act fits into a larger
context that
throughout our united states history
well beyond slavery
you know we think about racial
repression and we think that
with emancipation that all of a sudden
we were a free country
but a bigger point to make is that
if we think about a middle class a
middle white asset building
class it was government policy that
generated it
what little economic successes black
people were able to have at this time
often spurred a lot of resentment among
whites
this led to thousands of lynchings of
black people
and other violent attacks sometimes on
entire
black neighborhoods and communities
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this was in the time of heavy jim crows
in the time of
you know rising clan and in the time
when white supremacy was gaining this
pseudo-scientific legitimacy
[Applause]
it is the case that throughout history
not only have blacks not been permitted
to accumulate
land capital and other forms of resource
to the same extent as whites
but when they were able to overcome
barriers and accumulate
those resources it's always been subject
to
outright terror outright seizure because
we did not have the codification
that comes along with government to
protect the resources of black people
in the same way that it was protected
for white people
tulsa for example in the 1900s it was
oil boom with
a lot of wealth that was in that
community and so they built you know the
greenwood district and
the central part of the city was this
black church it was very ornate
beautiful
you know these places are called the
black wall street where it wasn't a
sharecropping market there were land
holdings
the thing that happened was that the
racial resentment grew
there were you know bombings and really
just a complete
just destruction of that of that city
and very much
stemming from that resentment
in that one day black wall street was
destroyed and ten thousand tolsons were
displaced
there's even evidence that world war one
bomber planes were used to burn the town
in tulsa alone the property damage
amounts to about 200 million dollars in
today's money
the tulsa massacre was not an isolated
incident
about a hundred of these occurred
between the end of the civil war
and the 1940s destroying a substantial
amount of black wealth
on the one hand those communities are
clear examples
of the ways in which black people have
demonstrated
they can not only survive but it can
actually thrive
[Music]
but on the other hand we romanticize the
past
we describe a nostalgia as if we had
these kingdoms of gold when in reality
it was never the case that black people
had wealth on mass
that said left to our own brothers the
wealth gap is not going to be solved
slavery itself created a multi-trillion
dollar wealth gap
and the period immediately following
slavery didn't do anything to close it
and none of that includes the one thing
that most people today
can trace their wealth back to
home ownership
following the great depression congress
passed a series of laws
to help the country recover from the
economic crisis
among them was the 1934 national housing
act
this law for the first time made home
ownership affordable to working class
individuals
and that was a good thing except for the
fact that it intentionally excluded
black people
that mortgage companies did not lend to
black people in fact
the federal government went the other
way federal government as well as local
governments
they facilitated the process of
excluding black people
from these products and how did they do
so neighborhoods were redlined
the government created maps that showed
the level of risk by neighborhood
these had different colors and the
riskiest was outlined in red
this was very much a crude calculus but
sophisticated in a way that they
actually had
tons of maps across the country and you
you would see the
the way that they mapped out a
neighborhood and they looked at the
houses is it single family is it
industrial is it
you know farmland what are the
characteristics of the neighborhood but
the number one thing that they looked at
is
who lives there right so they would say
this is a black neighborhood
red line and naturally wood would
develop slums
what would develop neighborhood
degradation when you have
capital fleeing certain areas and
capital being flooded into areas
the outcomes become obvious
if you lived in a black neighborhood and
because it was a black neighborhood
you did not get that fha mortgage you
did not get that gi bill loan you did
not get the farm
loans so today the legacy of those laws
is that your neighborhood
is very much racially coded this is how
racism gets embedded in wealth
word came from capitol hill that
congress had passed and sent to the
white house
the civil rights act of 1968.
included in the measure was a landmark
open housing bill
which when fully effective would forbid
discrimination in approximately 80
percent of all housing
offered for rent or for sale in the
united states
the civil rights movement and in
particular the fair housing act of 1968
try to put an end to that discrimination
fair housing for all
all human beings who
live in this country
is now a part of the american way of
life
but they didn't have much economic power
and they struggled to undo the decades
of damage that had already been done
since that time the wealth gap has
actually widened
in 1967 black families had one-fifth the
wealth of white families
today that number is one-seventh and
that
really is a legacy of the racial wealth
gap it's not just
that you have more money in the bank
account your house
is higher value it is also you know
the opportunities the ladders up for
your kids are different in certain
neighborhoods
non-existent in some neighborhoods and
quite frankly
hard to fall off of in other
neighborhoods
you know this story is not all dismal
just like
policy can be enacted to create these
unjust disparities
likewise policy can be enacted to
rectify them
what we need today is a new policy
regime that provides that
resource in a way that's anti-racist so
that we
all can have the opportunity for capital
accumulation
and intergenerational transfers we need
something in perpetuity
that ensures that as a birthright
no american is excluded from
the economic security it comes along
with
a capital endowment
you